Today's One Minute Monday is: "Be consistent."
I recently got a message on YouTube from one of my long time viewers, Shuffz.
Thank you, Shuffz!
He wrote in to say: "Hey, I've been out for a while. Great to see that you're still doing this!"
Every day I'm posting videos to my YouTube channel. Every single day new videos go up.
You have to be consistent! This is the problem with a lot of entrepreneurs, ok?
You start something and they you stop, you start, you stop, you start, you stop and never gain any momentum.
You need to do something every single day to grow your business. Consistency is SO important!
And I know you may only be a part-time entrepreneur, ok? You may have a job, you have other responsibilities.
I'm not saying jump in and do it full time every day, but every single day, if it's 1/2 hour a day,
... you're taking one action; you have to be consistent, because that's how you're going to grow your business.
Believe!
For those of you watching and liked the video, thumbs up below. Leave a comment.
Click on my face, subscribe to the channel.
I'll see you soon.
Subtitles by the Amara.org community